two percent oh i'm sorry
what's next uh what's up
oh really what is it
these are the ladies of the ensemble for
your edification
the ritz brothers out of work
i say what next on the agenda
the next actress award
miss landsmith miss collins yes miss
winter
are we up for anything the only thing we
are up for darling is grabs
these americans
do you suppose it could possibly have
anything to do with that boston tea
party oh no dear you're batting a very
sticky wicket true after all they did
nominate our darling deborah
and there darling david
there david i thought that he was one of
us
not anymore we traded him in for doug
ferbecks
oh well
chin's up
it's fully it's not to be nominated good
show not to be nominated
just to sit and not pretend
it's over in a minute and if you didn't
win it it's loud unless the winner is
overcrowded
in every art house
you'll find the space of us
the great and the nearly
performance said something else again
you have to be most fortunate to get the
proper part a role like susan's nose or
shells which proves you know your art
nominated wizard not to be nominated fun
to be just also
ran
oh there's susan hayes hello
she didn't let walter ranger down
susan hayward i didn't even know she was
back in town
oh there's shirley mclean
there's a talent that's rare
if you like
delinquent hair
oh look there's elizabeth taylor
tell me darling what she got i'm kidding
what do you think made the tin move so
hot
what a marvelous day
your mother could have scored as auntie
may hello
well i guess that covers every star
the darlings we've forgotten deborah
deborah paget no dear deborah carr
it's pleased not to be nominated
not to be
nominated capital not to wear the holy
grail
and now with your permission we'll
dispense with math
and bring you greetings from the land
that gave us birth
and tell you that next year we'll try
for all
right
weather not to be dominated
miss diana witter angela lansbury and
miss joan collins a real cheer everybody
a big vow ladies
keep going keep going
splendidly done splendid thank you